[Music]
only the most broken people
[Music]
can be great leaders
first I have to say
um looking at the poster knowing what we
saw from the trailer folks are going
into this thinking that you guys are
antagonists obviously but I think
they're going to be surprised to see
y'all bring a lot of different shades to
this relationship Leticia talk about
that because you and to know y'all share
a lot through this film and what you
both are going through is something I
think it's uh the same sides of grief
yeah it's um
it's an approach that's not typical it's
much easier to say this is black this is
why this is bad this is good but with
the script that Ryan gave to us it's
more complex than that there are
personalities
um that are more complex you know we
meet one of the oldest characters of the
MCU
um of the comic books and and and he's
filled with wisdom and and we see them
go on that Journey it's quite it's not
what people would expect but there's a
lot that people shouldn't expect and
should expect and
November 11th kind of says it all but
it's um
but it was a it was a complex but really
cool journey to explore that with to
notch because yeah man it really pushed
me to the air well I mean look we see it
from the trailer you're talking to each
other and you're very much stating
you're going to protect your Homeland
you're going to protect Telecom but what
I think is very interesting is how much
you are trying to seduce wakanda through
shuri and how much you were trying to if
you cannot uh get them on your side it
goes to war talk about that because I
think that aspect of the relationship
you know I might call him Mr Steal Your
Girl Named more I might I might just a
little bit
man no it's it because for him it's a
natural Ally you know it's natural it's
like okay we went through the same thing
you know we have the same thread we have
the same enemy and uh in a way we share
the same wood wood so for him it's
natural to to make an alliance with them
but then how they solve the problem is
different and of course he's more than
500 or around 500 years old so he tried
everything he saw everything that's why
after half a millennia he said no there
is just one solution you know because he
went through different deceptions and
you know scenarios and he was a witness
of the world the world so it's like okay
girl there is not other way that's why
he's so practical you know but it's like
it's the same yeah it practical but the
same to your point um Leticia I will say
this um coming into this one you had so
much going on so much both emotionally
and then the task at hand but I do have
to say this this man gives a stare he
gives a stare what was it like seeing
him in like all of his glory for the
first time and some of these very
intense scenes that y'all have going
together yeah man the first time seeing
to Notch was
really really powerful
um I always remember like when it's his
it was his turn to be on camera the
first introduction of of Neymar in our
film and I was trying to look give him
my eye line and hold it together and
give as good as I'm getting and I just
kept looking at the monitor like dang
this is good so
um he's just a a another addition to
what is a great Ensemble yeah yeah it is
an ensemble and and Ryan really talks
about how you guys built it together it
was a grouped effort and he told me a
story yesterday you were not at the
interview he did yesterday for sag
um which is like the award that they won
last time with black panther was up but
Ryan confessed that you to Notch and the
other folks from Telecom were actually
responsible for this whole thing and
that y'all were the ones that said the
wakandans have this we gotta have our
own thing so you got to tell me this
story so but this was from y'all y'all
like went up to Ryan so talk about that
conversation and how like I think
gracious he was to do that yeah well we
uh especially I'm I'm a passion
passionate guy uh about Mike history you
know my my roots in in Mexican Latin
America so I knew some things from the
ancient cultures how respectful they are
and some signals or whatever so we
decided to do this to find a kind of
identity cellular you know and and I
think it's really accurate and by the
way we have these advisors they they are
Mayans they grew up in Mayans Community
they are they are professionals and they
provide with all the information all the
background to create this fantastic
world and made it the boss uh respectful
way yeah no and that was actually what
so many people have remarked on is just
the Grandeur the colors and the richness
of these worlds that you are living in
and I will have to say so much of that
was imagined on set I know you guys are
not knowing where this stuff is when you
see it but one thing that was always
present and such a big part of this was
relationships that that you guys dealt
with and each other and what the first
film dealt with Fathers and Sons this
one definitely deals with mothers and
their children and and that sort of like
Eternal Mother Love talk about that one
in this one because especially it's not
a bad gig to have Angela Bassett play
your mom when you're gonna do a really
intense mother-daughter performance yeah
not bad at all
it was again just Ryan's
Ryan's you know mind and and and
alongside Joe Robert Cole just just
tapping into the lives and the and those
characters that
um was so close to t'challa you know and
seeing ways in which they have to
navigate this new this New Path
um without him without their their
thought that Baba without their husband
or father or father and um
it was just a relationship that you know
in those moments those are the those are
the relationships that gets tested the
most you know you get to see who's
really there for you and who can really
comfort you and I feel it was brilliant
to have Angela on set because it was
also it was also not only
helpful for sure but helpful for me to
have that that that that mother figure
of nurture going through this process
yeah and it's Angela
we will get Justice for 93. thank you
both thank you so much they came from
the water
they had superhuman Strife he's coming
for the surface world
that can't be good first of all
congratulations on the film the film
again it is incredible and I want to
talk about Nikita I want to talk about
so many things but there's a whole Riri
of this and it's not necessarily
Dominique Miss Rihanna
I'm bored to sing the song You Know
Rihanna has a certain girth about her
yeah her Persona and so it's great that
she's lent it to this story and that she
wrote that song as a tribute to Chadwick
you know it's it's again evidence of the
power of what he did with his life very
true and again that is the thing that I
think folks when they actually see the
film and see Nikia and where she is with
it you will see although there are so
many people in this movie that were
close to him and had very specific
unique relationships their relationship
is one that this film really puts
completely different in a completely new
light and what was that like because we
learned more of them as a couple in his
absence really which is interesting yeah
I I haven't necessarily thought of it
like that because obviously when you're
playing a character I'm very much living
in it
um but it was really lovely to see the
the evolution of their relationship
through this film and it was challenging
you know to play that role but I was
also really inspired by Simone Edward
Chadwick's wife I remember seeing her at
his memorial and wow she was just
working with a different kind of
strength and she really inspired me she
definitely did yeah and that's I mean
it's it's interesting too because
there's a kinship obviously they were
playing his love interests on screen and
obviously I know that the foundation I
saw his foundation was part of the
credits last night and obviously his
presence was throughout the film but you
weren't alone in this you had Leticia
you had deny you had Angela and I talked
to to the ladies earlier when I was sort
of talking to Nye about this you all
sort of formed a bond in that and and
that was part of the process I think
deny said it wouldn't have been possible
to do this if it wasn't all of you all
coming back and doing it together let's
talk about that I mean there's no way
there's no way we could have done this
if it wasn't to do it together
because when we lost Chadwick we were
all in isolation and uh to and he was
such a central part of this story so it
was only because at me I took heart in
knowing that I would be on a set with
people who understood the loss that I
was experiencing and were were
experiencing the it themselves that's
both cast and crew cork cast and crew so
we really did lean on each other to get
through this yeah I I read and you've
told me when you read the script you
went through a range of emotions like
reading it both you know weeping and
obviously feeling emotional for what was
on on the page but then also I know
you've confessed to me that there was
some frustrations in your early days
with the script and I do have to say
it's so cute seeing you and Ryan talk
about it because Nikia in this story is
not where everyone else is with her
great she's at a different level yeah
and she had yeah she I guess has access
to more information than other people
and so uh yeah she's just a further
along in the brief process than say
shuri or Okoye and I wasn't I wasn't
feeling that further along when Ryan
gave me this script I was kind of like
damn man do I have to know what's going
do I have to know how to handle this
um but no I really I'm grateful to him
for giving me this task because it she
actually playing Nakia helped me get
through my grief and put it it gave me a
place to put it and I just it felt
constructive to play here
I want to add this too because
um like so many other asks uh you also
of all of the wakandans I think spent
the most time in water and you had to do
that with weights and so I've heard
um if it's not worse than kids and
animals it's water yeah it nearly broke
the abyss and Water World here you were
and yeah no the water of it all that was
a challenge
um before this film I I was uh amateur
swimmer okay yeah and I had to get
comfortable with water I did um swimming
training and I also
um went further to do this training
called Extreme Performance training
where you work with weights underwater
and I remember seeing this video of
someone walking on the water with like
20 pound weights and I thought I'll
never be able to do this and in like a
week and a half I was doing it too
and it was really it really helped me
with my breath capacity but just to find
comfort in water because you need to be
very calm in water in order to succeed
and I never imagined I would act
underwater and take like directions so
it was really useful and I I felt really
prepared when I got to set my whole
mothers gave us its fear because it is
precise elegant and
deadly
it will not change under my watch
this I just have to say again thank you
so much for this film your performance
and it is absolutely incredible I will
start with this which is you have I
think so much going on in this film but
I'm just gonna start with that bridge
scene because ma'am
again like I've seen you do swords I've
seen you do spirits the casino scene
from the very first movie set a high bar
but you and Alex go at it on that bridge
in a way that even goes higher so talk
about that the physical demands of that
moment
uh they were no there was it was no joke
thank you it was uh it was a lot of work
it was a lot of work uh you know as I
was saying I was very I was very keen to
get into it quick when I read it on the
page I was like oh no what are we doing
here I need I need to know we need to
start working on this now like no we're
gonna do some Prada you gotta get into
the drills I'm like that's cute we'll do
that but I need to be working on this
because I know on the day I I have to be
yeah ready and so it was a lot it was a
lot of work and it's it's actually
um yeah it's uh it's very interesting I
still still trying to debate the how how
it exactly it was so intense that that
fight in terms of learning it
um and how you know as I said there were
some uh you know the shoulder at some
point started to say you know what I've
spent a lot of years taking care of you
you better start taking care of me so I
really learned about my shoulder learned
how to take care of it and help it out
it had gotten little tears here and
there you know
um but you know the work had to be done
and it was very crucial to me that you
saw um this encounter in its fullest
form but also that you saw
um you know her intentions of course was
to protect these girls and and you know
their intentions were what they were
um but you know it was very important to
see these two and also you know kind of
game meeting game in those two
characters who are both kind of the
equivalent of each other in their
various kingdoms yeah I'm gonna ask him
about the second half of that game meets
game and Trust I think it's gonna be
good also you mentioned the women in
this and obviously Dominique is a part
of that but more particularly between
Lupita's Nikia and then Leticia shuri
the three of you ladies together are in
this film so much but also as the three
of the four female veterans from the
original installment coming back to it
there's a bond that you you guys show on
screen that I've seen echoed outside of
it and I just think that probably was
the only way y'all could do this movie
was leaning on each other to come back
to do it I'd love for you to talk about
that because it's something I've gotten
a little sneak peek on and I just think
more people need to see it
no yeah I mean we are we're you know
we're sisters and it is very very um
much it was crucial to be there for each
other during this process and to lean on
each other uh I I remember many a time
doing leaning and and going into you
know someone's trailer and and you know
just talking about something figuring
something out praying over something
yeah and praying over everything really
um because it was there it did feel at
times very challenging walking through
telling the story and uh there was a
there was a lot that we were dealing
with in terms of our own grief and how
to how to navigate it
um and not sometimes you don't even
realize it's grief until some one time
Ryan had to explain to us he's like
you've just described your grief and I
was like
oh man like you know some and I think
okoya was similar she didn't she doesn't
even realize what her grief is you know
and I it is it was it was the parallels
were kind of insane that way but yeah we
needed each other more than anything
absolutely it's almost an uncanny valley
that you guys had to be acting in this
when you were living in in so many
different Echoes and chapters of it
again and so when you see the finished
product I think people need to
appreciate there is a Melody playing
underneath this that is not necessarily
seen on screen in every moment but you
guys are always fighting through it it
just makes the accomplishment that much
higher and so I do have to say like as
you sort of look at this especially with
General koye who learns a lot of lessons
in this one what do you think were the
biggest lessons about grief that you
guys took from from this experience and
these performances uh very much that
ultimately
you've got to surrender to it you've got
to let go
and I had to do that and she had to do
that
this is a hard junket to be a journalist
with y'all I am so serious I'm glad
y'all have makeup artists to follow
y'all around because I'm just making it
here next I want to talk about some
rereads
um because there's a couple there's a
couple this time around there's really
in the music and then there's a movie on
screen yeah and so now I've only seen
the movie twice and there's too many
movies
but Riri Williams I will say this on top
of Rihanna doing the sound she was
somebody who you're talking about not
just protecting her but she was I feel
like if there was a joy that y'all
needed on set she brought it this time
talk about Dominique and what she brings
to that one you know I was so excited
for Dominique I actually get a little
emotional when I talk about Dominique
because she's so special her her actual
story which you know folks need to know
and then the story of her character and
I think it's just what she's going to do
for girls for black girls for black
women just like how smart and and
amazing her character is but I don't
know if people realize she she's ivy
league educated with the like
biochemistry or something I don't know
if people realize like she could have
been at the the jet propulsion lab just
as easy
exactly it's just it's
first generation first child from her
family to go first first person from her
family to go to college like this girl
is incredible yeah and so and then when
she came on set I was just
I would act with her and it was there's
a scene where she's kind of she's
getting upset and and then the camera's
supposed to swing over to me
I was just laughing but she's so good
she's like oh let's crack it up and I
had I was like dang it because it was a
wonder and I was messing it up because I
was like I
like she's just so funny and she's but
the character it's rooted in a character
really just taken in this world and
trying to survive you know with what she
knows you know and so she's not trying
to she's not trying to be you know she
just is and so I just found her just
delightful to be around and just I'm
just so excited by her story and how the
world will learn about her and as a
person but also in this character that
she plays so well I think there's gonna
it's the impact of her characters is
something really great I love you
literally light up talking about her
like you literally a lot of talking
about her I'm not even done I could go
on about how amazing she was as a
support system when we had bad days and
what a beautiful soul Spirit she was and
how she'd pray for you and take care of
you in those moments it's amazing I love
that she's incredible
today I've lost their protector
I will say this uh again just
congratulations so much on the film that
is literally incredible I've now seen it
twice oh cool how was the second time
the second time was interesting because
I could like calm a bit like that was
the part of it that was very difficult
and the second time viewing was also
when I saw more of the little touches
especially of total Khan the parts of
wakanda we didn't get to explore in the
first one because we only got limited
time with it talk about those details
and the Craftsmen that you've worked
with with Hannah with Ruth and really
everyone that I know you had to work
with on this and the advisors yeah you
know it was great um a lot of detail uh
in in into the film
um wow detail went into the film I
should say and like uh with indigenous
cultures I think that especially like in
the medium of film so much of of what
happened to us about us I mean anybody
who comes from
um a group of people that's been like
calling lies marginalized historically
the details were scrubbed out yeah you
know
um they're simplified
ignored you know um not mentioned you
know so like for us we we take a deep
sense of pride in our duty to to focus
on the details you know what I'm saying
like to get the little things right like
because a lot gets lost in in those
details you know what I'm saying like in
fiction
that's popular that that comes from a
western bit you've got like talking
phase for example who are going to build
a whole language and hold lineages and
whole [ __ ] you know what I mean like he
wasn't glossing all of those details and
we've had
um you know centuries of
a century basically like you know a lot
of resources being thrown at filmmaking
from that perspective yeah you know and
I felt we feel like don't even like this
we got to make that right with this one
you know you know what I'm saying like
like um
uh and we and I had the people the crash
people to do it like I had had a big
learning Ruth Carter and the folks over
at visual development at Marvel
um you know uh I had the right producer
you know like uh and Kevin and Nate and
Victoria and Lou they they encourage you
yeah you know you know what I'm saying
and so we were able to get you know
every detail right name was headdress
and um we found oh they were peeping
from the trailer like from the trailer
people were already spying everything
that you put into it yeah so so I mean I
think I think First We Take we take a
lot of pride in in
um we happy to to go that deep and make
sure it makes us happy yeah I will say
last night at the SAG q a before you
guys walked in we had a woman from Haiti
she talked about I know those types of
beaches like she literally said she's
like I felt like I walked into a movie
and I didn't expect to go home and I
think it talks to the collaborative
effort that you guys put forth in this
and I think the the other thing too with
all of this is you put all these details
in what we see on screen and all these
rich collaborators but then within the
relationships and within each individual
you still found ways to take it further
if the first one was Fathers and Sons
mothers and the Eternal mother love is
like a huge part of this one yeah and I
think you said this in one of our
interviews like you had to bring
everyone back with something to do and
when you brought Angela back like I have
to just feel having seen the film I feel
a part of that was I want Justice for
93. I want Justice For What to do with
it and let me just ask you like that's
what I felt was that part of it because
you gave her a lot in this to sing with
really yeah
well I mean she can handle a lot like
she she one of those kind of actors
who's better with a lot to do you know
you know what I mean I'm work you give
her the better she's gonna she's gonna
be she was built for like Shakespeare
you know you know what I mean like it'd
be like having the best engineer sports
car and just leaving it parked somewhere
if we didn't if we didn't do it the
right way with Angela and it was
alarming for me because like I I
remember when we were making Panther one
I had a conversation with Nate who has a
a sister I don't have a sister oh I got
two little brothers I inherited sisters
when I got married you know and it's
fantastic but but um we were looking at
our scene with shuri and t'challa and
and we look towards each other hey man
how many movies are here about brothers
and sisters and he said well you can
count on me was great and it was like
man what's the other ones and then we
couldn't really it'll be two guys I
watched a lot of stuff like we can't
really find like like like you know um
and they and they're there they're out
there you eventually dug some up but not
that but not enough right like for a
relationship that that's so common you
know you know what I'm saying like like
so then on this one we did the same
thing for motherhood you know and it was
like yo how many movies bro oh yeah
and then it was like oh you know it was
like especially when it was us because
when it's us yeah like no no they're out
there more movies about moms than
brothers and sisters you know and I I've
seen some incredible ones since we had
that conversation Matt Maggie uh Maggie
Gyllenhaal's um The Lost daughter one of
them yeah which is fantastic but but I
was like oh man what opportunity you
know we get to tell a story about this
foundational relationship in life not
just Humanity you know what I'm saying
like it stretches to the Animal Kingdom
like this this idea of like take care of
your kids yeah but also like yeah this
idea of like mothers being dangerous
like if you if you camping and you see
and you see like Grizzly Cubs you know I
mean like like you know like you know
like you're in a bad spot you know like
you gotta find where your mom is you
know like are you in trouble you know
you know like like that that just that
concept that University out you know
this relationship that you know is inner
and fierce you know at the same time you
know um and if that relationship isn't
right
then then people struggle you know like
like um and and so it was exciting like
it's like oh man we get to make a movie
about motherhood like in this comic book
context it was exceptional man and yours
goes into the pantheon you've already
talked about this is there other films
that you really looked at into this one
because you I know are a cinephile and
like yeah it was time yeah just give me
a couple real quick as I get out of here
I mean like I I could talk movies but I
can also I I want I'll talk I'll talk TV
for a sec okay just give me a couple
before I go season two
Fargo season two Fargo season yeah Fargo
season two is a big one Terminator two
was a Magic win big giant action movie
about them all uh and a follow-up to
another to another fantastic film
contact was one very ambitious scientist
question in our faith Two Towers
also
[Music]
the [ __ ] was big a lot of 90s Cameron
yeah you know a [ __ ] Jurassic Park just
for scale and in philosophy but really
scary that's like that's like the best
scale movie like visually like showing
like big animals you know we got other
fish in this whales
where are we
and when I wake up Alex my bell I just
have to say thanks again we're gonna get
to spend some extended time which I'm
excited about because probably get to
talk to you two together and just say
y'all kick so much fun in this movie it
is absolutely incredible and I love that
even though you guys were joining
something and I know a strange moment
they just lost their leader it's a
castle of people who knew him well and
you're coming in as the the newer cast
members but you guys found a way to
bring Community even in that yeah um and
Ryan was telling me a huge part about
how you guys and tanuk came up with this
like that is just so cool Alex I'd love
for you to tell that story especially
about how you guys said you know we need
our wakanda forever yes listen uh I want
to start saying but
we would not be here today if it wasn't
for the Black Panther you know the Black
Panther open not open they knocked down
doors and everyone came through and then
you know that it it's such a it's such a
personal and special move for so many
people that to be part of this we
introduce into the Marvel Universe and
this one is is very special to me and
you know the wakandas are there's such a
such a tight community and and the term
wakanda forever it's so strong and
there's so much pride in it
that we were like
you know we have so much similar areas
to wakanda
we neither what kind of forever so after
having conversations with their Language
Coach you know which to to find uh the
correct translation we came up with
Rises which you know it's very essential
because we live at the bottom of the
ocean and in this one
with rice and we try different movements
for say that it's like
it's like okay but you know we them up
with uh
I dig that a lot
um mother I definitely have to say this
as well because your character she's the
perfect embodiment of you can be of so
few words but so much Fierce she's just
like should she she says few things
whatever whatever she says has meaning
and the thing I loved especially is you
didn't have to say much because you were
doing enough already you already had
everything that you you had going on as
far as this role what was the hardest
part was it the under water was it the
language was it the fact that this was a
big MCU movie what was of the many
physical and mental challenges you had
to do which one was the hardest attack
like that everything a little bit and
actually I think the biggest challenge
was my mind because at the beginning was
I can't believe it's like
why me
Victoria told me all the time is Mabel
you you need draws you you deserve to be
here so trusting you and was I think
that was the biggest challenge because
all the time to me is like oh I don't
want to make a mistake in the movie I
don't want I don't want to I was like no
you know what what do you need to do
because you you work a lot you I spend
one year training for the movie I spent
a lot of time training physical mental
with underwater with the language with
the costumes yeah and we we was ready
for the movie but but the mind sometimes
is it's crazy yeah it's different it's
challenging and it's such a beautiful
moment those days where you're just like
exhausted you're tired you're annoying
or whatever it is that's going through
your mind you know we all had separate
lives and things happen but when you're
in those moments and then you see your
your partner just going through 100
you're like all right you know they're
doing it gotta bring it yeah and then
you know it's like you pick each other
up and and you know we're a team and not
only a team you know the the telekinesis
but the whole production we were there
for each other and you know we yeah
lifted each other up yeah you can really
see that bond between you both on and
off screen I've seen you guys in a few
Garden moments before and it's really
like family you walk in and you know
it's just like oh and she got on
everyone is like it's like you know
family reunion time but I will say it's
not just with the folks from telecon
it's with the entire cast and part of
that I know is bonding over the intense
fight scenes y'all had as adversaries I
mean you saying Warrior is going to be a
thing that the internet is going to be
talking about but I talked to deny Ai
and she said she was just like on top of
this being like such an epic scene
there's a scene of you guys on a bridge
that I can't wait for folks to see she
said she was so happy because she was so
nice about it because he was like he
wasn't gonna hit me hard because y'all
have to like go at it like really so
talk about that and how you all develop
that sort of partnership to do that
those scenes together it was it was a
lot of training very intense you know
from from from from day one
it took it took so long to shoot this
movie not in in the sense of the amount
of days but you know it's like we
started shooting uh I think it was in
summer and well no the the first day of
the scene I think I believe it was late
October at November and then we didn't
pick it up back until uh late November
before before uh Thanksgiving and then
back in January and then in March so it
was it took a span of like four months
to complete this whole thing so we
trained so much and not only the
training learning the dance the
choreography but I got to know the night
yeah and that and that and that gave so
much more substance to our chemistry to
trust each other and I felt so
comfortable with her I mean the
comfort's on screen because you look
like you're about to tear a face off and
it's so unfortunately do uh I'm a bill
before I get out of here I definitely
want to ask you about the intricacy and
the details of the world you all get to
inhabit and the world we get to take
um a peek inside and but for you as
actors I know a lot of it was imagined
some of this is visual effects there's
some things you get to see but a lot of
things you don't when was it that your
character became real was it the first
time you saw her in costume like when
was that moment where you're like oh wow
like
I am part of telecon I think what's
under the water because I I asked Jesse
my assistant's record the the the screen
because I work like this it's like oh I
need look my face for for Maya details
and and that was the first thing while I
was like oh
yeah
oh my God
oh my God it's crazy it's crazy because
you never expect watch the movie and see
the world it's like hey you you can see
Australian it's uh uh you you you you're
gonna see a both it's like a boat it's
surely
in a boat and you know it's like yeah
it's crazy so it's that that was the
first time was that I see
oh my God I'm the Mora I'm a warrior I'm
in a Marvel movie it's it's crazy it's a
lot of things in mind you know my very
first day Winston told me listen you
you're gonna have an idea
look like you're gonna read the script
you're gonna leave all the details in
the description but once you see the
movie you're gonna be like whoa I
literally had no idea that this is gonna
look like this and and he was absolutely
100 right because when I saw it I was
like
yeah this is I really have no idea what
this whole thing was gonna look like
coming together